it's great to welcome to the program
today John Barry who is author of the
book the great influenza the story of
the deadliest pandemic in history also
professor at Tulane University's School
of Public Health and Tropical Medicine
John so great to have you on thanks so
we've heard a number of different
assertions made about the flu pandemic
of 1918 from the President and from
others sort of in the context of
coronavirus let's just figure out a
little bit more about that what are the
origins of that pandemic well no one
knows for certain like Koba 19 and
animal virus pollen torrents of viruses
have their natural reservoir and birds
but they can infect mammals an animal
virus jump species to humans spread
around the world
infected about the third of the world's
population and killed 50 to 100 million
people adjusted for population that
would equal about 220 to 440 million
people today so fortunately as bad as
kovin 19 is it's not nearly as lethal as
a 1918 pandemic what was the sort of
full duration as we understand it of
that pandemic well it really in total
covered from the spring of 1918 until
the fall of 1920
however 2/3 of the deaths perhaps more
than two-thirds of the deaths occurred
in a 14 or 15 week period in the fall of
1918 the first wave was very spotty miss
we're not really sure exactly but my
guess is it although it was pretty
widespread in Western Europe and in u.s.
army camps in the spring it probably
missed most of this country and most of
the world then a I think the virus mean
was also very mild so mild
there were medical journal articles that
said this looks and smells like
influenza but it's not killing enough
people so it's probably not influencing
that turned around very rapidly the
virus mutated and then you started
seeing scientists saying this looks and
smells like influenza but we've never
seen in influenza that killed like this
although it was of course in that second
way as I said 14 to 15 weeks from mid
September through most of December then
there was a third wave in late winter
and in early spring of 1919 so it's very
unusual to have two waves of influenza
in the same influenza season very
unusual so the virus had mutated again I
guess then in 1920 it came back and that
was pretty much it the virus probably
mutated further toward mildness and in
addition our immune systems having seen
it several times began to deal with it
more efficiently so it gradually became
seasonal influenza do you know the
president often refers to 1917 when
talking about that pandemic I have to
ask him okay you there's no there's
nothing been your understanding I have
history
nothing scientifically or
epidemiologically that would justify
calling at nineteen seventeen you know
my guess that he said it once and he
doesn't like to admit any error over
even the tiniest things
so rather than correct himself in future
he just kind of wrapped his arms around
it as he seems to do with other mistakes
fair in terms of the name often called
the Spanish flu can you talk about
number one why it has that name but also
sort of the early hot spots that we
and think about as the places where it
really started to spread I most likely
explanation for the name is that Spain
was not at war the warring countries
censored the press I didn't like to
print anything that was negative that
might hurt morale that might hurt the
war effort
Spain wasn't at war plus the king got
sick celebrity culture then is now so
the Spanish press wrote about it and
other newspapers around the world wrote
about it and picked up the name Spanish
Influenza except in Spain where they
called it other things
the first known eruption was actually in
January in rural Kansas of southwest
corner of the state and in early
February we see it in New York City you
know it hit the army camps in first and
camp Funston in Kansas Ford Riley in
early March spread to about half of the
army camps in the United States during
the spring seemed to travel with the US
troops to Europe although would have
gotten there anyway as I said it was in
New York and almost certainly other
places even before the army camp so it
would have spread eventually but the US
troops did seem to bring it to Europe in
late March and April they accelerated
the spread and you know it
as I said earlier widespread in Western
Europe
Ludendorff the German commander launched
an offensive to try to win the war
before American soldiers arrived in
large numbers he blamed an outbreak of
influenza among his troops for the
failure of that offensive of course
I think that's looking for an excuse
there
influence on the other side of the
trenches as well although the first
known cases were in January in rural
Kansas the scientific community thinks
that the and it is possible that it
actually started there but and I
advanced that hypothesis in my book but
there's been a lot of work since my book
came out originally in 2004 and I myself
had backed off the Kansas hypothesis I
think it's more likely it started in
China other other hypotheses on some
very good virologists think it started
in France Viet Nam's the possibility and
you never know it could have been New
York City most virologists think that it
was circulating for at least a year
perhaps learning how to better infect
humans and in some think it was
circulating for a couple years so again
we'll never know where it actually did
start that spring waving was spotty and
mild in July the first widespread
outbreaks of the lethal second wave were
noted in Switzerland in fact it was it
was so bad in Switzerland US military
intelligence report said that this is
being called influenza but it's actually
the Black Plague of the Middle Ages hmm
wasn't it was influenza when it when it
comes to the obviously Medicine was very
different at that time international
travel was different at that time media
was different at that time when it comes
to mitigation what was it that was done
you know we talk about the quarantines
and the shutdowns are unprecedented and
in a sense they are but there were also
some of these techniques to probably
back then
exactly most cities in the United States
not quite all of them but very close to
all of them closed all sorts of things
they weren't actually quite as Extreme
as what we've done they closed places
public gathering schools etc most of
them did it too late to have maximum
impact just as I think in the United
States we close down too late to have
maximum impact as we're speaking there
was a study from Columbia University
that came out today that said if we
close down a week earlier we would have
saved more than one third of the lives
that of law have been lost so far and if
we close down two weeks earlier we would
have saved about 60% of the lives that
have been lost so far similar things
happened in 1918 most cities closed down
too late to have maximum impact when we
think about the communication that we
now see of federal and state guidelines
here augmented by television radio
internet social media etc how was it in
1918 through 1920 that most people were
learning about what was supposed to be
done
to stop the spread well of course print
was the only media you didn't even have
radio yet you had rumor and you had
print we were in a different situation
than because of the war the government
the Wilson administration focused
everything on winning the war they
passed a law which made it punishable by
20 years in prison
to quote Otto write print or publish any
disloyal profane scurrilous or abusive
language about the form of government in
the United States so you could curse
some action the government took and you
just broke the law truth was not a
defense this law was prosecuted
vigorously
congressman was sentenced to more than
10 years in prison for this law it's
also the one that a couple of memorable
phrases came out of the Supreme Court
decision which actually upheld it Oliver
Wendell Holmes who is generally
considered a signal you know real
upholder of freedom of speech actually
wrote the opinion upholding this law and
he used a phrase clear and present
danger in his opinion along with the
analogy you can't shout fire in a
crowded theater to justify upholding
this law anyway that was important
because and also the government had
created a propaganda arm and the
architect of that what was called the
committee for Public Information I wrote
that
nothing an experience teaches us that
truth is superior to falsehood the value
of an idea lies in its inspirational
value it matters very little if it is
true or false so on the one hand the
government was lying to people in order
to keep morale up for the war on the
other hand they were threatening people
with 20 years in the can for telling the
truth if the truth seems critical of the
government so influenza fell into that
infrastructure National Public Health
leaders associated with the government
said things like this is ordinary
influenza by another name or you have
nothing to fear if proper precautions
are taken neither of those statements
were true but they were echoed in most
places around the country many you know
not just echo but quoted verbatim in in
most studies so initially people
we're led to believe this was ordinary
influenza by another name but it didn't
take long
we're talking about almost a matter of
days before they realized this was
something very different I wish we had
more time to dig into it further but I
do want to make sure people know the
book is the great influenza the story of
the deadliest pandemic in history and
we've been speaking with the book's
author John Berry from Tulane University
John I so appreciate your time you're
very welcome